we're right in the middle of a very
interesting and globally significant
story whose details are changing so
quickly that by the time today's episode
goes live you may actually know more
than i wrote know right now and it has
to do with nancy pelosi the speaker of
the house in the united states the
country of china
and taiwan
and understanding some of the history of
the united states china and taiwan is
important to understanding what's going
on which we will of course get to to
begin with the big story is nancy pelosi
is was at least as of this morning
expected to visit taiwan according to
taiwanese
and united states officials and as cnn
says nancy pelosi is on a tour of asia
and despite warnings from biden
administration officials
and from china
nancy pelosi is believed to be heading
to taiwan
this is certainly uh controversial when
it comes to china because of the policy
of the united states
of at least
for
foreign relations and geopolitical
negotiation purposes
recognizing china and china alone
although the u.s has supported taiwanese
membership in a number of different
coalitions and organizations over the
years sort of staking out
not what i would call a 50 50 position
on china and taiwan but certainly not a
policy that is as extreme and
reactionary as what china would want
which is to pretend that there is no
such thing even as taiwan
sort of out in the world this would be
as the cnn article says the first stop
in taiwan
for a u.s house speaker in 25 years
it is not currently on pelosi's public
itinerary and this is being interpreted
one of two ways
one way in which this is being
interpreted is they've decided to bail
on the taiwan visit
the counterpoint is well it just was
never on the itinerary so it's a signal
that she
may still plan to do it but it's at
least not being given the same sort of
position and significance
uh that other visits are being given by
virtue of not being placed on the
official itinerary the taiwanese
official added that pelosi is expected
to stay in taiwan overnight it's unclear
when she would be in taipei the u.s
official added that defense department
officials are working around the clock
on monitoring chinese movements and
securing a plan to keep nancy pelosi
safe china has issued warnings uh saying
the military will not stand idly by
if nancy pelosi visits taiwan now the
least i don't know if charitable is the
right word to use here but
the least charitable or most aggressive
interpretation of this comment would be
that the chinese military would target
nancy pelosi specifically
that does not seem to be the consensus
opinion right now
but there's a lot of questions around
what's going on this is a reuters report
which says
the latest warning was issued during a
chinese foreign ministry regular
briefing
spokesperson xiaoli zhan also said that
because of pelosi's status as the number
three official of the us government a
visit to taiwan which china claims as
its own
would quote lead to egregious political
impact
pelosi was set to kick off a tour of
four asian countries monday in singapore
with speculation that she risks the
wrath of beijing by visiting self-ruled
taiwan
this is a very interesting geopolitical
story
and also potentially of significant
consequence because u.s china relations
are not particularly strong right now
donald trump by virtue of his
what do we even call it belligerent
posturing about taiwan
about china rather
has
arguably sunk those relations to a new
low a year of talking about the china
virus
certainly didn't help and although
things have not further escalated under
joe biden they certainly haven't been
repaired in any significant way
the official position of the united
states when it comes to china policy
is not overtly supporting taiwanese
independence but supporting taiwanese
membership in some international
organizations that includes the wto the
u.s says okay we don't recognize
taiwan's independence but we recognize
that taiwan as an entity should be part
of the world trade organization well
usually it's countries that are members
of that so it creates this kind of
arguably deliberately nebulous situation
um the u.s has supported taiwanese
membership in the asia-pacific pacific
economic cooperation forum the asian
development bank now you don't need to
be an independent state to be a member
of the asian development bank so it's a
generally speaking pro-china policy that
is not pro-china enough for china and we
will see what happens here we will see
what nancy pelosi ultimately does and
probably in the next 24 to 48 hours we
will have more news about it who doesn't
love a good cereal the crunchiness the
sweetness it satisfies
in a serious manner but then you grow up
and now all the healthy cereals are
boring and bland and they get soggy and
this is where magic spoon comes in it is
that sweet crunchy texture you loved
from childhood with zero grams of sugar
only four to five net carbs perfect if
you're doing keto only 140 calories per
serving and packed with 14 to 15 grams
of protein magic spoon spent years
developing the recipes it's really the
only cereal on the market to get the
texture and the flavor right without the
sugar and without a ton of carbs they
have flavors like cocoa honey nut fruity
peanut butter maybe you want to go
adventurous they've got blueberry muffin
maple waffle cookies and cream or
cinnamon roll that brings back memories
i love magic spoon the whole team does
but if you don't you'll get a full
refund but i know it's about to become
your new favorite cereal you'll get five
dollars off when you go to
magicspoon.com
pacman the link is down below